let's talk about
him against aoc what happened when they
were trying to go to new york and
hey we're going to bring a 125 000 jobs
at an average of a 25 000 jobs at an
average of 150
000 a year cuomo wanted it but de blasio
aoc they kind of pushed him out we don't
want you to come here you're going to
increase
rent you're going to do that and he's
kind of like wait a minute what are we
talking about here i'm just bringing you
good jobs
how did he handle that and what caused
them to finally say
screw it we're going to go a different
direction they didn't handle it very
well
they were fleeing a political storm in
seattle where
the amazon had started to become blamed
for
the problems of growth like
gentrification and homelessness and
rising home rates
and that precipitated the hq2 search
that and the fact that they were kind of
running out of space in seattle
and you know they whipped up the country
in a frenzy of competition for for hq2
folks probably remember that 238 cities
applied
you know they were talking about things
like the low cost of construction they
were looking for
affordable home prices uh the size of
tax incentives
good transportation networks and then
they pick new york in washington dc
and so right off the bat you know the
world's kind of shocked because that is
not what they set out to do
and where they it's where they ended the
most expensive
exactly um and and look and and i tell
the story in the book i've got the
internal memos
the decision process was largely driven
by by the personal preferences of bezos
and the leadership team
so they go in there they get de blasio
and cuomo to agree
on on the amazon package in long island
city but the city council
isn't informed and and the dynamics of
you know political dynamics in new york
are such that
you know whatever de blasio wants is you
know the council is going to kind of
reject
aoc had just been elected and i think
the surprise for amazon was that the
same political dynamics
you know that were hurting them in
seattle were there in new york
you know the big tech companies the tech
lash the fear of gentrification
um you know so the political backlash
starts
bezos is in the helicopters at the time
so he asked for a helipad
in the in the queen's headquarters and
uh you know the new york post puts it on
the front page
and they're off to the races and and
ultimately you know they were sort of
unprepared for the backlash they didn't
really get their message out
and then the whole thing kind of
crystallizes on the issue of unions
and whether amazon would allow its
workers to unionize and bezos has always
thought that from the very beginning he
sees it as
kryptonite for the company and so when
you know what i concluded was that when
talks went to unionization
and they saw the political landscape was
the same as it was in seattle
it just wasn't worth it for them and
they they pulled out they grew instead
in manhattan and then
in in washington dc or in northern
virginia crystal city
you know it almost seems like he's okay
with taxes increasing he's okay with
raising minimum wage he's okay with a
lot of things
but he is not okay with the union uh
union unionization of amazon why is that
right well um you know
what they'll say and then we'll get to
the real reason is that they don't want
an intermediary between them and their
employees
but let me put it this way you know the
the amazon website is 24 7.
you can buy in the middle of the night
right you can buy on a holiday you can
buy on a sunday
and what that means is that the company
really has to get as close as possible
to a 24
7 operating cycle and to go scale
up and during the holidays or when if a
pandemic breaks out and
someone's suddenly buying or if there's
a sudden surge in interest for a
particular piece of merchandise
and then they scale down afterwards so
they're hiring and they're firing and
they're working around the clock
and they're suddenly you know if there's
a backlog they're shifting employees to
different jobs
and all those things patrick that i just
described are things that you know a
union
that's going to you know very quite
naturally want to instill some order on
their workers lives
and create some employment security is
going to collectively bargain against
and so i think amazon's viewed unions as
a as an impediment
to their ability to push employees to be
flexible and to churn through workers in
the fulfillment centers as the needs of
the company change
that's probably the most charitable way
to put it um
you know but um you know we've seen
again and again around the world
amazon walking away from from facilities
when the discussion turns to unions
yeah you see like even what was going on
with georgia he's like
right the day before they announced that
uh uh you know they were about to
announce that hey the voting all that
stuff that was going to take place the
day before
he goes up and says i think we should
raise taxes and i think we should
you know p the rich people should pay
more taxes and then the next day the
union topic just kind of went away
it almost seemed like behind closed
doors there was a negotiation saying if
you
say something about raising taxes will
make uh atlanta go away or georgia go
when it kind of did
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]